uh boom once we completed fleet
pre-flight training we entered primary
flight training
at any one time in 1968 there were 10
flight companies
in session you ended up you you get to
pick well you
i guess you draw what kind of helicopter
you're gonna fly now you're told okay
you get you're told
and you get the th-55 love that aircraft
looks like uh uh
looks like kind of a dragonfly looking
yeah it's the uh
it was bought the army bought them right
off the shelf from hughes aircraft
and in the civilian world it's a huge
300. uh
you started the engine up and then you
engaged the clutch which engaged eight
rubber bands
that started turning the main rotor and
uh so we got that going for us yeah i
got them before
but the thing had a ton of power and
down here in texas in the summer
the oh-13s and the 23s the other two
training aircraft
they could barely get off the ground
th55 would spring off the ground so
it was just a great little aircraft to
fly i loved it
awesome um
about two months into our flight
training we returned from the flight
line and we were told to get in company
formation right away
once all 275 of us were assembled
as we'd have had about 75 drop out of
the class at this point our company
commander came forward and addressed the
class
one of our fellow classmates crashed
that day and was killed
that was something none of us had
considered at this point in our training
his death would not be the last either
another student and his flight
instructor were killed in a mid-air
collision
with another aircraft flown by someone
from another class
how there weren't a lot more merit
midair collisions always amazed me
a little bit of a wake-up call well it
was you know you had
roughly around 1200 aircraft at eight
o'clock in the morning leaving
and coming back in at 11 o'clock and
then leaving again at 1 o'clock and
coming back at five o'clock
and most of them were flown by students
so you know the students had anywhere
from
10 hours to 50 hours or let's say you
got up
yeah you got 100 hours total while
you're in
flight school early flight school first
stage there so
you had a lot of inexperience out there
running around in not that big of an
area
and why we didn't have a lot more air
midairs i have no idea
the the one student the first student
that we lost
he flew into a cloud and we hadn't had
any
weather instrument training yet at that
point well he went in the cloud and
people that saw him he came out upside
down he was inverted
and uh you just don't invert in a
helicopter it doesn't work
so that he got killed that way and then
the other one was a student an
instructor and another aircraft slammed
into them
we lost them there those are the only
two that i knew about there were others
that that did happen in other flight
classes
but we were kind of fortunate we started
out with 350
we graduated i think one 150 somewhere
in that neighborhood there
get done with that it's on to advanced
flight training
um this was i
i kind of had to there's there's a good
leadership lesson here that i wanted to
jump into
it says we're approaching the end of our
instrument training when we return to
the barracks from the flight line
the night prior to the meteor
meteorology
exam mr clinton wasn't happy with the
condition of the barracks
and had gone on a rampage aided by a
bottle of jack daniels
beds were overturned wall locker
contents were fl
were lying on the floor the fire hose
was spraying water
and the contents of everyone's foot
lockers were everywhere except
in the foot lockers he was on a tirade
one cadet was singled out
mr clinton was berating him evidently
the cadet was responsible for
his five o'clock shadow mr clinton told
the cadet to get into the push-up
position
once there he placed a razor on the
floor in front of him and told him to
shave
the cadet looked scared and i was mad i
had had enough of mr clinton's crap
with all respect for his rank that i
could muster i stepped forward and
gotten clinton's face
sir you've been drinking and you are
drunk if you do not leave this minute i
am going straight to the company
commander and have him resolve this
situation now
leave i shouted there was dead silence
mr clinton just stood there and glared
at me with his bloodshot eyes everyone
was watching
finally he laughed turned and staggered
out of the barracks
everyone including me sighed with relief
we spent most of the night getting the
barracks back in order
and no one had an opportunity to study
for the weather exam
it showed the next day the exam was in
the morning when we returned to the
barracks after flying in the afternoon
we were immediately informed by the
company first sergeant
that we were all restricted to the
barracks until further notice and i was
to report to the company commander's
office
when i arrived the senior officer from
the weather committee was present as
well
i was told to sit down cadet corey
do you know why i've restricted the
company and called you here the company
commander asked like i was some
clairvoyant and i could read his mind
this was the first time i had ever
spoken to the man again
dad's words of wisdom came to mind no
sir
i replied knowing this wasn't the time
to be a smart ass
it appears cadet corey that most of your
class failed the weather exam
we need to know why he stated oh [ __ ]
most of the class which includes me too
again as class leader it was my fault
didn't you study for the exam last night
asked the weather committee instructor
who didn't look happy
why did i suspect that [ __ ] rolled
downhill here and it was coming right at
me
however i was seeing a u-turn for this
[ __ ] storm
no sir we did not study last night we
had a party instead
i replied their eyes bulged and i
thought both men were going to drop dead
from heart attacks you did what gag the
company commander you had a party the
night before the most
one of the most important exams in this
course do you realize by by having a
party and failing that exam you could
all fail flight school and be sent to
infantry immediately
yes sir i replied and let them stew on
this revelation
now the weather instructor had a grin on
his face as he turned to the company
commander
well i guess the problem wasn't with the
instruction but with the discipline of
these cadets
i was beginning to see what was going on
here somewhere above their level the
[ __ ] had hit the fan and someone high up
was looking for
somewhere to lay the blame the army
needed helicopter pilots at this point
had spent considerable money training 80
cadets
the army couldn't afford to wash out 80
cadets at one time the company commander
wasn't looking too good right about now
cadet corey why in the hell would you
have a party the night before a major
exam
sir we had no choice i answered
sheepishly i was beginning to enjoy this
i had been around the military long
enough to know when people would have
stayed a panic over something that had
gone terribly wrong
oh dad you taught me well what the hell
do you mean you had no choice the
company commander
sir when we returned from flightline
last night mr clinton had torn apart the
barracks to include
turning on the fire hose and told us to
get the mess cleaned up before morning
we had a barracks cleaning party to get
it squared away and that took until
midnight
light out lights out was at 2200 but we
worked on stuff
until dark until we had it taken care of
only the married men had a chance to
study last night
you're dismissed cadet corey and there
you go so you
you you then up you know you go to the
company commander then you end up with a
battalion commander
and the school commandant and the school
commandant finally
uh you end up all assembled
the battalion commander comes out i am
lieutenant colonel barlow your battalion
commander i have not met most of you and
normally do
not meet cadets until graduation however
because of this incident i have met some
of you and thought i should meet all of
you
what you have experienced is not typical
of the treatment of cadets
changes have been made the first being
that you have a new company commander
major kid or will be your company
commander for the remainder of your
training mr clinton
sergeant first class [ __ ] will no
longer be
your tax either major kidder and he
turns it over
the uh to back up a little bit
our class got a bad rap the first the
very first day we showed up
me and another guy we had flown into
savannah the night before
so we had a 1200 hour report him and i
got there at about 11.
so we we report on time the rest of the
guys
they all flew in on a flight that was
supposed to land at eight o'clock in the
morning but didn't because of the
weather
so they all showed up an hour late so
that set clinton off and for eight weeks
we never got a pass to get off the base
where every other class had blanket
passes on the weekends
and so clinton and and the man had had a
drinking problem and this wasn't the
first incident with him but this is the
one that broke camel's back
uh when he when he went through that
that
weather exam as as i said in the book
you couldn't afford to flunk 79 guys
right now somebody was going to go
ballistic over this
so it worked its way up and thank god
and we got to the brigade commander's
office and
they asked me they said why do you think
mr clinton did that and i said
well sir because he was drunk well
the three of them looked at me like do
you know what you just said you accused
an officer
of this well i was a little bit older
than most cadets i joined the army i was
the day i came in and all the other
classmates they were
19 20 year olds and been around the
military all my life i had an idea how
things worked
so i was i was going to play my trump
card and that's and that's where i
played the trump card was with the
brigade commander
you know over the next couple of days
they called in every day they call in
three guys
and they'd ask them the same questions
and and everybody backed my
my comments up so uh we got mr clinton
got rid of mr clinton got this
rid of sergeant [ __ ] and i use the name
sergeant [ __ ]
uh i never heard the guy ever speak he
had he had tattoos
covering them everywhere before tattoos
were popular
and so i don't know anything about the
man outside of he never said anything so
i figured it was more
but then after that we we went into our
advanced training
uh huey transition was the following
monday morning and things went along
really well after that with the unit
major kid him it was a
he was a great guy how did you like that
huey when you started flying it oh i
loved it
i still love the huey to this day the
huey's a fantastic
aircraft had plenty of power even the
delta models
had plenty of power they were forgiving
they were just they were a dream to fly
and they still are
it's isn't it great well i guess it's
not too crazy i mean i joined the navy
in 1990
and we still had huey's and they're
still huey's right now
uh the army's put all layers in museums
what about the marine corps
uh the marine corps has got a different
huey they got a big beefed up one okay
muscular things
twin engines and i'm not sure if it's
got four rotor blades or just two but
uh they've got a beefed up huey uh
that's much much bigger than the army's
ever wore
so it's great aircraft i mean why
wouldn't still be using today i don't
know
i mean we got the blackhawks now yeah
they're way bigger than i mean they're
way smaller than a blackhawk though
oh yeah yeah yeah tiny we could get uh
we could get
six combat troops uh besides the crew
crew four aboard
and had power to you know to do things
and stuff like that the blackhawk when
we assaulted into
iraq uh back during desert storm
uh there was 15 guys in my aircraft with
me and uh
my rto is my and i had one squad of
infantrymen with me when we went in so
much more power much more a much faster
aircraft and it was an aircraft the
blackhawk i was on the the test bed for
they were designed in case we went into
war with iran
and that's that's really what we were
looking at for an aircraft they could
get the altitude
uh the mountainous out mount altitude
around iran
uh to replace the huey and the blackhawk
was the
the choice over it they were two there
was a boeing put a proposal up for the
utas
and then sikorsky put a proposal up for
the utas it was called utas
at that time uh utility tactical
transport system
and uh sikorsky is the one that won so
and it seems like
when you look at the the huey it's like
a freaking 1969
muscle car just in terms of hey that's
the engine
there's you know you see the the the uh
aircraft now the helicopters
there's so many computer parts too it's
like when you open up the the hood of a
car
nowadays you don't know what the hell's
in there right it's all
you can't you can't fix any of it with a
wrench but you look at you look at the
huey who's the guy crewing the huey
the guy was eight 19 years old maybe 20
and he was the crew chief
and what those kids did with those
engines was just amazing they'd work on
them and you know
i was a pilot and the most dangerous
thing you could do is let the pilot up
there around the engine
my crew chief wouldn't dare do that but
these kids
they really maintain those things well
what what they couldn't do at the
operator level
at the crew chief level they went into
the the maintenance level which is right
there with our unit and they
were all 19 and 20 year olds doing the
sheet metal work and the electronics
i took a bullet through the through the
wiring bundle one day
and the wiring bundle was about that
thick
and it was maybe 35-40 white wires in
there
and i saw a kid sit down and sit there
and put each one of those wires back
properly to each one of them to get that
get the communications and
the electronics all working uh it to me
it was a bunch of spaghetti
so um let's fast forward a little bit
let's get to let's get to vietnam
um